There are hundreds of billions
of planets in the Milky Way, but
they're really hard to spot.
Humanity's search for
other earths has only yield a small
fraction of the possibilities.
If you're interested in
learning about exoplanets and
the techniques astronomers use to spot
them, keep watching after this video.
Anyway, that was fun.
I hoped you enjoyed learning a little
astronomy alongside JavaScript.
Of course you came here to learn about
Promises, the easiest technique for
handling asynchronous
work with JavaScript.
You learned how to wrap asynchronous
work in Promises, you chained
asynchronous actions together,
and you practiced error handling.
You experimented with
sequences of Promises, and
you tried different strategies to
convert lots of asynchronous actions
into long chains of manageable promises.
It's been a lot of fun.
I want you to go out there and
use Promises to simplify your life, and
you know what, don't forget to
look up every once in awhile.
[MUSIC]